now since boris johnson's resignation
all attention has focused on mps in
westminster and the ballots that have
seen the leadership candidates whittle
down to the final two now the power to
pick the next pm moves out across the
country to the conservative party
membership who will choose the next
leader so who exactly does that mean is
making the final decision
this research from 2020 shows how
conservative members are spread over the
various age groups 39 of them are over
65 compared to 19
in the whole uk population
the majority of conservative members are
male well nationally the distribution is
fairly equal a 2017 survey found that
members ethnicity was 97 white british
compared to 78 of the population in
england and wales
and most of the members live in the
south of england with only six percent
in scotland
so let's discuss it we're joined now by
lauren mckevitt a former government
special adviser who's not yet decided
who to vote for claire pearsall a
conservative councillor and former party
advisor who had been backing penny
morgan but will now switch to rishi soon
again alex dean public affairs
consultant and former conservative
advisor he's backing liz trust lauren
claire and alex thanks so much for
talking to us um alex let's start with
you
why liz truss
well for me and like to be clear i was
backing kevin vadenk until she was
knocked out you can't always get what
you want um i support liz trust because
of these two candidates i see her as
more of the free market
small state low tax kind of conservatism
i want that may not flow to everybody's
boat but it certainly floats mine and
rishi sunak whilst he faced of course
the challenges of coronavirus and if
he's prime minister i'd still be happy
i'd prefer liz trust because i see her
as more in the thatcherite mould and i
see her as somebody who's going to take
less of a kind of brownite approach
without money i suppose oh that's
interesting isn't it and we'll get back
to the whole issue of who's that's right
and who isn't but claire let's turn to
you now i was having a read through my
notes and it said that um you do find it
depressing but you will vote for rishi
sunak
yes that's right um i
started out actually supporting tom
tugan had because i thought that he
would offer a clean fresh start that we
all needed uh but then changed over to
penny morton so to have both of your
candidates your preferred choices to be
knocked out leaves you with the choice
between these two which isn't my ideal
and i'll be completely upfront about
that
and i think i've settled on rishi soon
act currently
because looking at the finances i know
liz trust is promising a lot of tax cuts
which everybody would like
but rishi does make the point that where
do we get the money from to support the
country you can't just keep cutting
taxes you do need to get that money from
somewhere and being fiscally competent
is what a conservative is all about
it's interesting you say and we will get
to this again we'll come back um to you
and specifically about
who who your ideal would be but in a
moment um so lauren
that's who they are going to vote for
that's who they back um you're undecided
yes well i didn't i decided not to try
and fall too heavily into one camp while
a whole other electorate of people was
narrowing the field down to two i
thought that all the candidates in the
field said some interesting things and
some slightly batty things um and i
think that the the race between rishi
and liz will be an interesting one i
find it interesting that alex is um
thinking that liz is more in the
thatcherite mould when in fact uh as
rishi pointed out in one of his hostings
uh his his husting's answers um liz is
uh of the two of them the only one who's
in favor really of looking at long-term
debt of war bond options and for the
possibility of offsetting against tax
cuts which is a more left-wing approach
to balancing the economy um
and i think that we're going to have a
very interesting debate over the next
six weeks the conservative party is one
of the oldest parties in the world and
we have reinvented ourselves more times
than all three of us can count and this
is an entirely new generation of member
of parliament running for the leadership
of our party and i really hope that what
that means is a very serious and great
debate about what direction our party
takes for the next 10 years um and so i
am happy to remain undecided and listen
to what the new generation would like to
debate
okay
so let's pick up on that thatcherite um
theme and go back to you alex i mean
sonic himself said my values are
thatcher right i believe in hard work
family and integrity and um your
candidate liz trust has said she isn't
um she has she's denied modeling herself
on margaret thatcher despite the t-shirt
the blouse excuse me and the bow we all
saw that um and she insists i am my own
person
yeah of course she's her own person one
seeking to read the runes on these
people as we were with the whole of the
candidate field to see who we think
most clearly reflects what we believe
and uh i think liz trust has a pretty
clear low tax agenda she spent some time
burnishing that in think tank land and
in her roles i liked very much what she
did on international trade to both the
rollover deals and the new deals but
look let's just say one thing and i
respect my two fellow panelists greatly
i would have chosen any of the people in
the field over uh kyostama and i think
any of them would have beaten kierst
dharma if selected so i know that some
people are looking at this and thinking
to themselves gosh the tory party it's
all blue on blue well yeah but on the
other hand we were very lucky to have a
field of talented candidates who i think
will take it to labour and whoever wins
is going to beat them my view is that
this is a reflection of the quality of
the candidates available in the tory
party bench that we have this kind of
conversation okay do you do you agree
that whether it's sonic or trust they
will both beat kierstamr
you're asking me yeah that's what i'm
sorry no no no i did say claire clay can
you hear me i can now yes
yes i yes i do think they can beat
kierstama i think that
one of the benefits we have as alex has
just pointed out is that our party has
an extreme amount of talent sitting
there what i do find a little
disappointing is putting out of a
fantasy cabinet list from both of the
top candidates this morning where there
are very very few women
and i would hope as lauren said that we
can reinvent ourselves to look at new
talent to look at women coming through
to make their voices heard around the
table what we don't want to see is
pretty much what we've had over the last
three years because in my mind that
hasn't worked so we need to change this
up and there is some exceptional talent
sitting there in either junior
ministerial or back bench positions that
need to be brought forward but nobody is
mentioning those at the moment so i
think we need to turn this round but i
do absolutely believe we can beat
kirsten armor
okay alice i just want to pick up on
what you said about increased borrowing
cutting taxes given that interest
payments on our national debt have hit
an all-time high new figures out this
morning do you still
back liz truss and think that increased
borrowing cutting taxes is not going to
increase inflation and it's where we
should be going
yes i do at the same time we've seen
plenty of economic studies saying that
the new chancellor will have and people
vary on their precise estimate but circa
60 billion of fiscal headroom to make
adjustments which are not inflationary i
know lauren suggested that this is a
left-wing approach to economics i mean
if it's left-wing it's also what ronald
reagan did so um it's an interesting
perspective on where the political
spectrum sits if you if you think that
that's uh left-wing i think that you we
should as a country be investing right
now to ensure that people don't get
another tax rise i think it's the worst
time to have national insurance hike
many times on your program kimberly
people are talking about the cost of
living crisis i think it's absolutely
the wrong time to be taxing people more
unfortunately electorally that's also
what people want they want their taxes
to be lower so it's useful if you can do
the right thing and a popular thing all
at the same time lauren when you're
going to decide looking at the next six
weeks what are the kind of things that
will sway you either way do you think
i think the thing that's going to sway
me the most is um what's coming in the
economy in the next six months obviously
both these candidates have the luxury of
campaigning where nobody in the country
needs to turn their heating on
we haven't reached the point of the
energy crisis in this country where
people are cold and i think the number
of people in work earning who are going
to be cold this winter is going to be
far higher than anybody is currently
assessing and that is something that if
either candidate backs
backs away from how they deal with that
then we're in real trouble and i'm
talking both about how we deal with that
in the immediate crisis terms and how we
deal with energy security and dealing
with environmental concerns such as
climate change in the coming years both
candidates have to address that very
seriously for me to begin to pay some
attention to them but where we come with
people who are in work and are feeling
the pinch more and more i don't think
either candidate is really talking
enough quite yet
about each of the tax bands and the way
that they impact upon people who are in
work and i'd like to see both of them
begin to talk more about that
and our role on the international stage
is going to be an incredibly important
one over the course of the next 10 years
because of our trading relationships and
because of how strong we as a country
have been in support of ukraine um and
both of them and how they outline their
international approach is going to be
something that i pay particular
attention to okay let's um let's look at
who's actually voting here right so
sonic doesn't really when it comes down
to it he just doesn't know the
membership like liz trusts us
well i would argue that liz trust
reaches a certain part of the membership
now where i live we fall into an older
demographic it's a
southeastern rural area
which does fall in largely into the 65
plus category as you showed previously
for membership and they are looking
quite hard at the finances of the
country but they're also looking at
which candidate is going to
look at the health service
that is a real issue especially in a
rural community you're looking at access
to gp surgeries you're looking at
hospital appointment availability and
transport
and neither candidate has mentioned that
at the moment so i'm not sure it's rishi
not understanding the demographics i
think he's just not talking in the
language at the moment that they want to
to hear so he needs to do a lot of work
on that liz trust will always always
have a base with a certain part of the
party but she equally then has to work
hard to to get over the sort of one
nation southern tory approach now we do
make up a large part portion of the
membership we can't be ignored just
because we're in the south east
so for her just to look at the red wall
seats at the moment will have a
detrimental effect on her campaign down
here in the south okay lauren claire and
alex thank you so much six weeks we'll
see how it goes thanks
thank you